Sam and Bucky appear to have hit a snag.
Production on the upcoming Disney+ series
Falcon and the Winter Soldier, which was to
shoot for two weeks on the island of Puerto
Rico, has been suspended after twin earthquakes
rocked the area.
It's not yet clear when shooting on the series
will resume.
The cast and crew of the series were all set
to arrive this week, but those travel plans
had to be scrapped.
The U.S. territory experienced an earthquake
measuring 6.4 on the Richter scale last Tuesday,
the largest to hit the island in a century;
it was followed by another, smaller quake
with a magnitude of 5.9 on Saturday.
The quakes killed at least one and knocked
out power across the island, which has since
mostly been restored, according to NPR.
Falcon and the Winter Soldier was to shoot
scenes on the Northern portion of the island,
in and around the small coastal town of Arecibo.
Although the quakes struck off Puerto Rico's
southern coast, the town certainly felt its
effects enough so that the Arecibo Observatory,
one of the largest facilities of its kind
on Earth, was closed down as a precautionary
measure.
Fortunately, a survey by drones detected no
damage to the observatory, which is key to
U.S. scientists' efforts to detect asteroids
which may be swinging close by our planet.
Since our boring old world has no Avengers
to counter such threats, let's hope the observatory
is back up and running with all due haste.
The filming of Falcon and the Winter Soldier
has so far proceeded with the level of secrecy
one would expect from a Marvel Studios production,
and as such, we're not sure why filming on
a sun-baked tropical island would be necessary.
That said, recent leaked set photos do happen
to show an ornate Asian-style garden adorned
with the flag of Madripoor a fictional East
Asian island which has appeared often in the
pages of Marvel comics, usually in stories
having to do with Wolverine or the Hand, the
ninja cult which is always harassing Daredevil.
It may very well be that Puerto Rico was chosen
as a filming location for scenes taking place
in Madripoor, with its natural beauty and
miles upon miles of beaches.
In any event, it looks like Falcon and the
Winter Soldier's production is going to have
to find a substitute, and quickly.
Sorry, folks the truth hurts!
"...I hate you."
Of course, location scouting and securing
all of the necessary documentation required
to shoot on location can be a time-consuming
process.
There are also sure to be plenty of other
variables at play when it comes to adjusting
Falcon and the Winter Soldier's filming schedule
to make up for the lost Puerto Rican shoot;
it's not known whether the production was
to move to a different location or back onto
another studio lot after shooting in Arecibo
was completed, but in either case, there's
sure to be some scrambling.
Even assuming that filming is able to resume
relatively quickly, there remains the fact
that there are all kinds of potential snags
to be hit in searching for another location
to sub in for Puerto Rico.
At this point, we give Falcon and the Winter
Soldier a 50/50 chance of sticking to its
announced fall 2020 debut but fortunately,
should the series' premiere be delayed, there's
another player waiting to come off the bench.
That would be WandaVision, which has hit no
such snafus.
In fact, production has apparently gone so
smoothly on the series that it's already been
pushed up from its announced spring 2021 premiere,
and is now said to be on track to drop on
Disney+ in late 2020 a fortunate turn of events,
and one that ensures that the streamer will
debut at least one of its hotly anticipated
MCU-set series this year.
So, rest easy, Sam and Bucky Vision and Scarlet
Witch have your backs.
We'll be sure to keep you up to speed on any
news regarding the anticipated premiere dates
for WandaVision and the adventures of everybody's
favorite best frenemies.
"Can you move your seat up?"
"No."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.